[Musique]
et je me suis dit c'est trop con - de ne
pas passer et de ne pas dire d'autant
plus que moi j'ai j'ai été assez malade
et quand j'étais petit
j'étais très malheureux ça fait rire
tout était malade petit jeu c'est
bien dit
[Rires]
sérieuses et les nerfs
il ya un type un jour il m'a dit mais tu
te plains que j'ai dit mais si je
m'arrête je me plante je gagne plus ma
vie
plus je me plains plus les gens ils se
marrent c'est extraordinaire
j'ai été opérée des deux bras c'est
vraiment
si de chirurgie il voit la télé va dire
c'est pas vrai il ne croit pas c'est
vrai
[Rires]
j'ai pas été opérés
en fait c'est peu mais très trop grosse
et elle va gêner l'inspiration et de
l'air qui va ressortir pas c'est pas
très propre alors il ya des solutions
radicales
l'opération est plus ou moins grosses
suivant les suivants les personnes oui
c'est pas standard la bête
c'est un peu comme si on regarde et liam
et moi par exemple il a une grosse lui
est mais un émoi une petite mais c'est
pas toujours
en très très dur de terminer
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on a une
grosse couette on se fait opérer à 8
à quoi pensez-vous je pense à la
présentation d'une émission de à cuire
pendant qu'un oeil ou plutôt deux temps
par une maman
pas tout de suite
madame
parfaite derrière comme ça
parfait mais merci beaucoup docteur
d'être venu nous voir et de nous avoir
parlé de ce problème de vue qu'est la
presbytie et on pourra parler
prochainement également de tout ce qui
est hyper métro pie ix mis au pis tout
et tout les avait fait tous les défauts
optiques liées soit à une malformation
soit soient à la merci beaucoup
cher nathalie dans notre grande série
des déglingués
nous allons maintenant passer
commencé mardi matin à l'homme de
constipation ballonnements d'hp
respectiez maintenant semedo foncé
ménopause
c'est la ménopause quand on aime on ne
compte pas voici quelques conseils
et billy la pression qui va faire la
météo complète présenté par michel touré
22h48 ce soir sur la droit et dans un
instant de résumé en images
votre régime soit la
tagab
alors c'est quoi ça ça c'est la gauche
d'aujourd'hui
alors pourquoi moi je ne sens rien alors
signalé çà normal il n'est pas encore
mis pour l'asile allez-y alors je devais
plus puisque with plus plus plus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
utile ou futile pour commencer externe
mais c'est toujours utile ça faisait
beaucoup et florence tout à l'heure oui
c'est pour eux c'est la suite non oui ça
pourrait être la suite si maintenant et
c'est le récent passé la nuit au dixième
de l'amour c'est sa petite fille c'est à
dire ce qui est intéressant c'est alors
vous pouvez vérifier regarder
sérieusement ça ce nom oui je pensais
que ça serait si c'est non non non non
je sais pas si c'est la taille normale
veniez ne sais pas ce que c'est a séduit
quoi ça sert je n'invente équipiers je
sais quelque chose qui s'adapte à tous
les systèmes cohabitent avec abrutir
lundi c'est un entonnoir universel à
d'accord nous en fait partout en vain
ils s'adaptent
s'émerveille devant les autres prenez
pour des envies tu as
fait exprès ou quoi mais non fondée
je sais c'est que je suis pas très
surpris
jacques tati qui sait quelqu'un très
raisonnable d'habitude c'est quelqu'un
que je connais et là j'avoue je sais pas
ce qui s'est passé un
sale et ont lâché un jour
quand tu transvase un liquide d'un bidon
par exemple dans un autre bidon j'ai dit
en général ça sa fuite en met plein
non attends j'ai rien dit là
donc la place et dire qu'il y a quinze à
vingt millions de polonais qui sont
organisés en permanence dans des queues
et c'est que secrète leurs propres
dirigeants leur comité social de que
leurs dirigeants naturel île secrète
leur propre droit par exemple il ya en
juillet la tempe les films d'al gore
île secrète leur propre jurisprudence
par exemple il y à l'égalité de tous
devant la queue mais lorsque il y à une
femme enceinte elle n'a pas une priorité
absolue mais elle dispose d'une vitesse
de progression améliorée dans là que
j'avais lorsque là qu avance d'un cran
elle elle avance de 2 ou 3 même chose
pour les invalides ou pour les retraités
accompagnées d'enfants en bas âge bref
il ya une économie politique de là que
réside ailleurs car
le libéralisme c'est à dire que les
polonais sont prises sont propriétaires
de leur place dans la grille de la tente
dans la file d'attenté oui il ya aussi
également alors ça c'est très amusant et
ça va plaire peut-être notre amie
nathalie regarde nathalie je vais en
faire la démonstration
et j'espère que ça va marcher ça va
intéresser aussi le futur papa que nous
avons parmi nous notre futur papa est
connue regardez c'est drôle alors
non mais regardez c'est qu'on ne ratons
laveurs cette partie est très utile
on peut faire des choses dans cette
émission
écoutez
l'accueilleront brinon
[Rires]
à leur égard
comme
cela non mais ça contre le coeur du
petit bébé il y à un mouvement qui se
produit j'ai passé ensemble
[Rires]
merci catherine garder le sérieux pour
moi alors le maître suprême du micro ch
un ronronnement
alors on peut le régler
selon son désir des vibrations bombe
règle l'accueil de jour
et en lui mais
d'accord nathalie c'est très mignon ma
petite puce toi tu arrives pas voilà ce
que tu prends les choses très au sérieux
sur un design petites antennes égal à
bien regarder plat de riz au lait oui là
messieurs kirin on sait pas pourquoi
voilà mais c'est un juge ou très très
très utile oui il paraît que ça serait
te plaît et puis regarde ses rosés c'est
mignon comme foire aux vins blancs
j'ai fait les deux philippe il ne reste
plus que patrice deux voies pour une de
ses jeunes fils eh bien comment il
s'appelle la dernière la diète sandra
sandra bah oui elle ses opus elle s'est
intéressée à des bijoux de famille qui
comme toujours intéressant robert
laffont alex peut aller nous allons
passer quatre mois la séquence suivante
c'est à dire de vous continuez à voter
par minitel ici de relever le niveau de
ce jury s'il vous plaît montrez nous que
vous êtes de véritables espic directeur
du service public il n'en peut plus
perron maisons fleuries ou alors vous
avez un numéro de téléphone 36,15 god
fr3 au départ
les infirmières qui qui bourré qui
mouraient beaucoup dans les hôpitaux il
c'est incroyable
et je termine avec ceux ci qu est ce si
c'est un attelage une boule d'attelage
qu'est ce qui se passe à l'heure
actuelle c'est que la boule d'attelage
une fois qu'elle est montée et bien pas
la démonter faut prendre des outils faut
prendre toutes sortes de choses et c'est
extrêmement pénible ça très remarquée
pas du tout du tout oui non et on
s'était dit ça serait bien de pouvoir la
démonter cette doute parce qu'on s'en
sert pas tout le temps
c'est bon ça sert pas tout le temps à
ces loi
et l'ordre et la terrasse est pour
l'instant vous ne pouviez pas le faire
surtout pour cent c'est en général que
deux trois fois par an voilà maintenant
c'est possible en chinois
il ya un petit un petit système avec une
clé qui vous permet de la clip c'est
sans aucun problème
alors il faut savoir c'est que c'est pas
commercialisé encore est le seul
inconvénient c'est qu'il faut quand même
avoir le système d'attaché non
y accrocher cette boule
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'il n'ya pas retard on en
parlera
c'est parce que ça nous arrangerait la
macbu la ba écoute ta poule a derrière
lui marc je vous propose pour nous
remettre de nos émotions d'aller à la
cuisine en valeur
chose nous allons voir maintenant
comment faire un bon chèque à
ses études accord avec ce que marc
voulez devenir français assène marc marc
marti fait souvent de la cuisine chez
lui et il me disait en fait le québec
s'est ainsi facile à faire et c'est vrai
que c'est assez facile quand on a une
recette simple comme la tienne mais ces
deux cd moule et s'est déroulée sans
compter qu'ils aient pu exister sans
rapport après on va le voir très vite
parce qu'un petit papier c'est le choc a
dit à l'afp voilà il ya un petit papier
doré
alors voilà on mélange bien et assez
longtemps lait
le beurre et le sucre enfin les oeufs et
le sucre au pardon
et dès que ça commence à être bien monté
voilà
voilà l'appareil est homogène le voilà
dix ans le mélange avec les oeufs
qui sont bien monté 1
voilà
on mélange le tout
pardon oui alors il faut que ce soit
bill marque
éviter c'est la deuxième fois qu'il
vient c'est le casse avant la fin de
l'émission je reviens collaborer on a
peur et le fond du moule et on est bien
à pied voilà on vide de journée un peu
cabot vite pendant que tu vas le faire
en fait jean luc moi je vais vous
quittez un court instant mais bien sûr
on allait fermer
pour faire les génériques lancés pour le
sommaire simplement merci beaucoup à
marc lavoine d'avoir été avec nos petit
à petit feu le single et puis marc
lavoine lavoine o matic voilà c'est les
deux derniers albums de marc lavoine à
bientôt marque et puis on mangera du cac
en sanglots
longuement pour grossir comme ça c'est
pas difficile
regardez il ya trente litres d'huile
dans la poêle il ya plus d'huile que de
poils
c'est vrai plus dans la brique
d'ailleurs le problème c'est de maigrir
c'est un peu leur dire que tu as fait
aussi là elle a fait sa vie cigare aussi
bien heureusement des cigares aux
annonces alors là c'est
45 kg
vous êtes vers 2h après midi vous
attaquez le miel
dépendance à l'héroïne
ça ça regardez spa 10 et 15 450 mille
calories
truc on de notre team qui son anorexie
tu manges pas après deux jours et là
nous avons de la nourriture
à peu près 30 millions
[Rires]
à la règle
pour elle c'est normal
rigole
noël c'est normal tout ça
donation de préface de connaître deux
chroniques
interculturel pour faire plaisir à
pierre arditi monsieur mercier bébé à
londres il ya une exposition de mort de
bavent de plus de 10
ces merveilleuses que vous faites
est la bienvenue mais aussi de mesurer
si vous aimez l'art contemporain le
quotidien britannique 'the independent'
vous conseille d'aller à londres voir
cette exposition magnifique
pourquoi je vais vous dire ce que
l'explication du coup il est au pouvoir
rien notre temps la contre performance
pour être tous
[Applaudissements]
merde
je leur
fais sauter le pleure c'est une cata
[Musique]
comment sur
deux temps que la loue est tombé en mer
du bateau qu'il a été récupéré par jean
louis c'est jamais facile eric dumont
lui a perdu eric dumont lui à perpignan
mas pardon et il est en train de rallier
actuellement les antilles c'est pas
c'est pas facile et c'est donc jean
morel et fred dahirel que l'on attend
avec nicole bricq bizarre excusez moi
alors leur temps là sur la plage ait
bernard vous nous emmenez toujours sur
la plage mais moi je suis fixé
au tragique ô combien c'est la lettre de
benoît zèle tantale mailhiot demeurant
rue fauchier à marseille elle nous écrit
ceci
voilà cinq
essais font du
bien d'autres en juillet
j'ai en permanence d'avoir un récipient
sous la forme
et de nos rangs perret cuvette lorsque
j'en ai je besoin
force ajoute mme loiselle mouillot
demorand us ou
cheveux c'est le robinet qui commence à
avoir du jeu le flou qui a fait un devis
mais je voudrais faire
préparation partie par la propriétaire
et je n'arrive pas à mettre la main
dessus que te fâche
est plus drôle d'histoire dans la région
de xertigny les vaches connaissent
quelques petits problèmes de vêlage une
maladie qui sévit depuis deux ans a
certes signé qui laisse perplexe les
services vétérinaires jugez plutôt les
vaches de monsieur rouleau souffre de
nom de dilatation du col de l'utérus
pendant la gestation ses vaches pourtant
bonne santé sans jamais montrer des
signes de maladie sont prises de subites
contraction
puis un joueur d'une hémorragie ou
d'épuisement
seule une pratique rapide d'une
césarienne
là puisque le col de l'utérus reste
fermé quelle que soit la période de
l'année à laquelle ce
set m'a dit le plus étrange en pierre
c'est que cinq jours après la césarienne
tu vas arriver peut-être à dire le col
de l'utérus des vaches opéré s'est
dilaté les analyses et les prélèvements
réalisés nauche donné aucune réponse
quant à la cause de la maladie ce qui
inquiète monsieur rouleau qui voit son
cheptel diminue d'année en année et tout
ça pour une histoire de col fermé était
comme hiver jean pierre
fut mais aussi parce qu'on va consacrer
un dossier
complet à la filière agroalimentaire
régionale parce qu'en poitou-charentes
et bien et 23 mieux salariés un chiffre
pour que vous compreniez bien 14 des 25
premières entreprises exportatrices du
poitou charentes sont dans
l'agroalimentaire ça vous donne tout de
suite il a aussi une idée de la grandeur
du de la chose
continue et puis
demain appris à répondre c'est penser
c'est dans le maine-et-loire pour vous
proposer un truc où il y aura beaucoup
moins de fusils de fumée s'est amusé un
seul site local qui s'est spécialisé
dans les coiffes traditionnelles
il ya vraiment deux magnifiques
réalisations c'est d'une finesse
exceptionnelle moi je vous rends le truc
pas s'effrayer je cède ma place après
quatre ans dont quatre ans pour monter
un club en champagne alors un club qui
marche relativement bien depuis sa
création depuis quatre ans vous pouvez
déjà dresser un petit bilan de 85 de vos
animations de vos réunions oui en quatre
ans il marche très bien parce qu'il a
une trésorerie très saine
et plus oui où poser les questions
incessantes
[Musique]
qui est derrière nous
au niveau des animations tout
lorsqu'on ne sait pas par exemple c'est
qu'au bout de l'île de nantes via les
quais on les doit aux america riaa
lesquels que l'on voit encore
actuellement ses quais
entre là c'est la poutrelle de béton
entrelacés sont en fait des quais pour
l'essentiel américain et puis dernière
chose département a eu lieu donc
des sièges le 27 juin le 26 juin 1917
est-ce que ça a été un tournant
alors ça a été un tournant sera pas
immédiatement mais à terme c'est un
tournoi extrêmement important niveau
stratégique dans la mesure où
effectivement
donc ça permet à l'armée française comme
dit pétain d'attendre les chars et les
américains de relancer effectivement
l'aspect militaire
[Musique]